the mountains of akra in northern iraq
have been decorated
[Music]
the city is a destination for kurds from
all over the region to mark new rules
[Music]
the spring festival
they celebrate the rebirth of nature
nauruz means a new day in the persian
language
it's a family gathering occasion
hannah came with her relatives from
kirkuk city for them nowruz represents
resurrection and fertility
we used to celebrate no rules every year
in our home city but this year we've
come here to akra because it's the
capital city of naurus we'll remain here
until tomorrow and we'll do the rest of
the rituals
the event marks the first day of the
spring
it starts on the eve of march 21st every
year it is celebrated in several regions
with colorful traditional outfits
participants light flares
no ruse has been added to the list of
unesco's intangible cultural heritage of
humanity
these players symbolize victory of light
over darkness
and liberation over oppression
the u.n has praised
nowruz for promoting peace and
solidarity between generations
this year's festivities are significant
because hostility and destruction are on
the rise
around this region
in the morning families reunite with
nature by heading to the nearby fields
[Music]
that's part of the rituals to welcome
the arrival of spring
they sit around with traditional meals
but the food varies from one country to
another
people from other nations have come here
to share the event
even trying on local traditional outfits
well i hope
that this kurdish new year will bring
more uh better times for the people
because people and uh
in here have suffered a lot under uh i
mean you have the problems with isis and
other political problems
and the people they want to live freely
for the people in iraq's kurdish region
nowruz also refers to rising up against
tyranny
it's a festival for all aryan people and
each nation marks it according to their
heritage and traditions for us it's very
special because it's the top national
holiday
it's been a difficult year for many here
last winter devastating floods caused
substantial damage
and some young kurds who sowed a bitter
life abroad
died of the cold weather on the
belarussian polish border
now the burdens of the cold season are
being replaced by spring freshness
union between nature and culture is a
message conveyed by these ancient
rituals
city northern iraq